Jesse smollett's hate-crime story begins
to utterly collapse
president Trump prepares to declare a
national emergency and the 2020
Democrats move even further to the left
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show men sometimes there is so much news
it's almost impossible to get through
all that we're gonna get through all of
it and we're gonna do mailbag questions
that's how fast we move here on the
bench of hero show but first let's talk
about how you can make your business
better one way to make your business
better is to get better at hiring
there's only one place you can go where
hiring is simple fast and smart a place
where growing businesses connect to
qualified candidates that place is zip
recruiter com
slash daily wire multiple job sites
stacks of resumes a confusing review
process all this stuff used to make
hiring a dumb process but not with zip
recruiters comm slash daily wear zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards but they
don't stop there with their powerful
matching technology zip recruiter scans
thousands of resumes and they find the
people with the right experience and
then invite them to apply to your job as
applications come in zip recruiter
analyzes everyone and spotlights the top
candidates so you never miss a great
match zip recruiter is so effective that
80% of employers who post on zip
recruiter can equality candidate through
the site within the very first day and
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that zip recruiter comm slash at
daily wire zip recruiter comm slash Dai
ly WI re zip recruiter is indeed the
smartest way to hire there's a reason we
use it here at Sayle wire when we are
looking for new job candidates we're
constantly hiring which means we are
constantly using zip recruiter you
should - zip recruit comm slash daily
wire to try zip recruiter for free
alrighty so we begin with the shocking
but not so shocking news that Jessie
small its story seems to be falling
apart you'll recall Jessie smollett's
story mean streets of Chicago 2:00 a.m.
goes down for a Subway sandwich and he
leaves apartment goes to the subway
picks up his sandwich and on the way
back suddenly out of nowhere he is
accosted by two presumably white Magga
fans who come up to him somehow identify
him from the show Empire which is weird
and then start yelling the F word and
the N word at him at which point they
string a noose around his neck begin
kicking him in the ribs pour bleach on
him and he's only missing from the
cameras for like 60 seconds because
Chicago has lots of cameras there's a
60-second period where he's missing from
the camera when he re-emerged us on
camera he's got a clothesline around his
neck he is still carrying his subway
sandwich because as we have discussed
before this is always what you do I mean
if you get in a fight if somebody is
beating the living hell out of you
threatening your life threatening to
noose you shouting this is Magga country
while doing so your first priority keep
the sandwich I mean honestly they should
hire this guy at Subway that's how much
the that's how much this guy loves
Subway I mean he can take a lickin and
keep on tickin and carry that subway
sandwich at the same time so 60 seconds
later he walks back on camera now he's
got clothes lying around his neck and
he's carrying his subway sandwich he
strolls right through the lobby of his
building past the doorman goes upstairs
waits 40 minutes and then calls the cops
at which point the cops show up and they
say what happened he still got the
clothesline around his neck at this
point and he says well all this stuff
happened and they said okay well can we
see your phone cuz you claim you're on
the phone with your manager at the time
and he says no why would you wanna see
my phone Hey at this point if you are
not suspicious of the story it's because
you believe what you want to believe and
there were a lot of politicians who as
it turns out believes what they wanted
to believe about this story we're
talking everybody from Nancy Pelosi to
Maxine Waters to Kamala Harris Nancy
Pelosi said the racist homophobic attack
on Jesse Smollett is an affront to our
humanity Maxine Waters said it's coming
from the President of the United States
he's dog whistling every day Kamala
Harris said this was in attempting and
attempted modern day lynching and
politicians all over the left-wing
spectrum decided to weigh in
AOC said there is no such thing as
racially charged this attack was not
possibly homophobic it was a racist and
homophobic attack if you don't like what
is happening to our country then work to
change it it is no one's job to water
down or sugarcoat the rise of hate
crimes and the reason that she tweeted
that is because Entertainment Tonight
had originally run with the headline
Jesse Smollett has been hospitalized in
Chicago after a possible homophobic and
racially charged attack okay the reason
they said possible is because it might
not have happened is because it might
not have happened right which makes it
awkward that it might not have happened
and anyone who heard this story your
first thought had to be was this real
hey every element of it seemed like too
much every element and whenever there's
a story where every element seems like
it's too much you
think to yourself maybe this is a hoax
unfortunately there have been lots of
racial hoaxes in the past where people
claim to have been victimized in a hate
crime and it turns out not to be true
this one smelled like a hoax from the
very beginning nonetheless jussie
Smollett was treated with all of the
sensitivity due to his claim and
specifically because the media loves to
run with the narrative that America is a
racist homophobic place this became top
news across the country even though the
claims didn't make any sense again two
guys in the dead of night in Chicago in
ten degree below weather who watch
Empire but also our mag offends and
we're screaming at jussie Smollett that
night this is mega country in the middle
of Chicago which apparently went 193
percent against Donald Trump in the last
election cycle so it was a very weird
story from the beginning that didn't
stop the media from jumping all in with
both feet
Good Morning America featured Jesse
Smollett on their show yesterday where
he cried and he acted it's like he's an
actor or something he said I am NOT weak
I'm not weak why did you hesitate to
call the police there's a level of pride
there we live in a society where as a
gay man you were considered somehow to
be weak and I'm not weak I'm not weak
and we are as a people are not weak um
well no one was suggesting that gay
people are weak that doesn't answer why
you wouldn't call the police when a hate
crime takes place against you like
that's a weird answer and then he says
he just couldn't believe that people
were doubting him how how could people
doubt him it's just terrible just just
terrible I'm pissed off what is it that
has you so angry is it that the attacker
is the attackers but it's also the
attacks it's like you know at first it
was a thing of like listen if I tell the
truth
then that's it because it's truth then
it became a thing of like oh how can you
doubt that like how do you how do you
not believe that it's the truth and then
it became a thing of like oh it's not
necessarily that you don't believe that
this is the truth you don't even want to
see the truth no it turns out that we
sort of believe that it might not be the
truth because ABC Chicago reported
yesterday in a shocking blow mainstream
media hardest hit that jussie Smollett
was probably not telling the truth about
this here's ABC Chicago's ABC 7 Chicago
report last night police are now
questioning the two people seen in this
surveillance photo one an actor on
Empire Chicago police say there is no
evidence the persons of interest were
involved in that physical attack
described by Smollett multiple sources
are telling Eyewitness News that
Smollett and the two men are being
questioned by police for staging the
attack allegedly because his character
was being written out of the show now it
is true that Fox came back and he said
oh we weren't writing Jesse out jesse
was never gonna be written out of the
show so we have a bunch of conflicting
stories but here is what we do know at
this point ABC 7 Chicago said that
Smollett failed to appear for an
interview with detectives earlier on
Thursday they say that they were
investigating whether these two men
staged an attack the way that they
tracked down these two guys is by going
through Jesse smollett's phone
apparently the report is that he had
turned over an Excel spreadsheet with a
phone log that had deleted certain calls
so they compared his actual phone log
which Vegas they'd subpoenaed with the
calls that he said he had made and then
they only looked at the ones that he
told him and that's how they tracked
down these two guys he had said in that
Good Morning America interview by the
way that those two people in the picture
walking down the street those weren't
definitely definitely the two guys who
attacked him so you can't have it both
why about both ways either he is telling
the truth and those are the two guys who
attacked him and it turns out they're
his friends or he's not telling the
truth and those were not the two guys
who attacked him it was another two guys
who attacked him a source briefed on the
smella investigation confirmed to ABC
news that Chicago police are questioning
the two persons of interest one of whom
has actually appeared on Empire the law
enforcement official also told ABC News
that the homes of the persons of
interest were raided on Wednesday night
police removed shoes electronic devices
and any other items they believe could
help determine if the two people played
any role in the assault neighbors
described a swarm of officers and k9
units Jamey Figueroa a neighbor said I
was walking in the alley one police car
stopped in the alley and they told me to
go inside the house but then by then
five minutes later there were like 20
police right here by the door
neighbors said they believe the men who
are Nigerian are brothers who grew up in
the apartment and have lived there for
years neighbors described them as
friendly and possibly bodybuilders and
said they have long wanted to be actors
Chicago Police said they cannot confirm
any of those reports no charges have yet
been filed earlier police said the two
persons of interest are not suspects and
have not been charged
investigators are only talking with them
at this time the two were picked up
Wednesday night at O'Hare International
Airport and a lawyer who said she was
representing at the two persons of
interest declined to comment on the case
as she left area central police
headquarters Chicago police said they
were tracking these two people and they
were aware of who they were for quite a
while so this is led to accusations that
Chicago PD out of fear of being called
racist was slow-playing the revelation
that this may have been a setup and a
hoax so here is the theme that we should
we should take from this wait for the
evidence it's amazing this thing
happened within a week of Covington High
School the entire media lept to the
conclusion than a bunch of white kids
and harassed a Native American man on
the steps of the Lincoln Memorial during
the March for Life right they they
jumped to that conclusion why because it
fit a narrative and then Jessie smell it
told the story that was ludicrously
unbelievable on his face and the media
left to the conclusion that naturally it
was racist white men on the streets of
Chicago that had caused the problem what
does this say it says the media are
looking for a narrative the narrative is
racist white men do X that is the
narrative the media are looking for they
don't require any further evidence
whenever that is the narrative they're
willing to jump on it with both feet it
also explains why it is that the media
will pay inordinate attention like truly
grand attention to anti-semitic attacks
by white supremacists will pay no
attention to the vast bevy of
anti-semitic attacks taking place in
Brooklyn every single weekend apparently
why because as the New York Times itself
admitted it doesn't fit the pattern
narrative that we are seeking the reason
the jussie Smollett case is important is
not because an actor allegedly lied to
the police it's not because of that it's
because the media are always willing to
jump with both feet on any story that
backs a claim that America is a racist
terrible place and then they will slowly
walk back the claims as it comes out
that that's not true we've seen a bunch
of these cases recently there was a
player I believe his name was Michael
Bennett for the Seattle Seahawks and he
claimed that the the racist police in
Las Vegas had physically
salted him tape came out it turns out
that he had resisted the police and he
had run away from them these sorts of
cases do happen which is why the the
appropriate thing to do now in a time
where people do fib for media attention
where people do know what the media
wants and then feed the spoon feed those
narratives to the media and where the
media are willing to run with those
stories the best thing you can do on any
story it's something that I've morning I
think everybody is learning you got to
wait 48 hours for anything you got to
wait 48 hours for anything if a story
seems too good to be true unless it is
confirmed by a wide variety of sources
you have to wait 48 hours because there
is a very good shot that within 48 hours
the entire story will collapse this this
happens to be true with racial hoaxes
but it's true across a wide variety of
stories as I'll explain in just a second
first let's talk about how you can save
on legal bills this year if you're
determined to start a business or secure
your family's future in 2019 it's easy
to get distracted by hurdles that pop up
along the way
legal hurdles some of those hurdles
that's why Legal Zoom is here to help
with our network of independent
attorneys licensed in all 50 states
Legal Zoom can help you navigate your
legal needs from wills and trusts to
LLC's trademarks contract reviews and
more Legal Zoom has helped more than 4
million people like you take care of
their responsibilities I've heard about
Legal Zoom for years long before they
were a sponsor I used to use Legal Zoom
for wills and trusts and estates as a
lawyer the best part is Legal Zoom is
not a law firm so you're not gonna get
charged by the hour
getting those exorbitant fees racked up
next to your name on the billing
statement make sure that this is the
year you finally do the right thing for
your family and your small business make
a difference in your life by visiting
legalzoom.com right now for special
savings be sure to enter promo code been
in the referral box at checkout Legal
Zoom is where life meets legal that's
legalzoom.com again use legalzoom.com
promo code been at checkout for special
savings they've got a wide variety of
services and is no longer restricted to
wills and trusts in the states now
they've got independents attorneys all
over the country who can offer you
advice as well go check them out Legal
Zoom calm and use promo code them
alright so as we know it is not just on
the matter of racial hoaxes and racial
stories that the media are willing to
jump with both feet it's not just
Michael Brown hands up don't shoot it's
not just that stuff it is also with
regard to president Trump is why we have
seen multiple false stories about
President Trump debunked over the past
several years
CNN you will recall ran with a story
about President Trump suggesting that
Donald Trump jr.
knew in advance about WikiLeaks leaks
and that he was coordinating in advance
about it and then CNN hadn't walked back
the report McClatchy ran with a report
that Michael Cohen was indeed in Prague
meeting with Russian agents they never
walked out report back but there's still
no evidence to support it whenever the
media leapt on a story that seems so
spectacular that it backs every aspect
of what they wanted to back your first
response should be hold up a second just
hold up maybe it's true maybe it's true
maybe it all turns out to be true but it
is not racist
it is not homophobic it is not bad in
fact it is quite good for us all to take
a deep breath and say let's wait for the
facts to come in before we jump we live
in a media environment however in a
political environment where even the act
of waiting is now considered a sin it's
a really it's a serious problem we have
a serious dense disincentive to do the
responsible thing and wait for the story
if you jump on the story and you happen
to be right then it's look you're the
reason you were right is because your
worldview is right the reason that you
knew that this story was true is because
your worldview has been verified and if
you wait then we say the reason you're
waiting is because you are not sensitive
to sensitive enough to the needs of a
particular community so if the Jesse
Smollett story came out and said you
know what I got some questions about it
then you were castigated as a racist and
a homophobe just for saying that you
want to wait for some answers like Josie
Smollett knew that that's why he said
that on Good Morning America that's why
he said he was bewildered by people who
are asking questions the question really
should have been what sane person
believed every aspect of that story from
the start now again maybe it happened
the way he did but without any evidence
I'm supposed to believe that - Magda had
had guys on the streets of Chicago at
2:00 a.m. attacked an empire after they
identified from the show wound
clothesline around his neck poured
bleach on him then loud allowed him not
only to escape with his life but with
his Subway sandwich I was supposed to
believe that otherwise I was part of the
patriarchy or something it's absolute
silliness so once again the media
crapped the bed and I don't think that
we should be particularly surprised
about that okay meanwhile the the
President of the United States is
prepared today to sign into law a new
budget deal the budget deal is not good
there's a lot of garbage in this budget
deal conservative review has a great
piece by Daniel Horowitz going through
what exactly is in this budget deal he
says the process it's indefensible it is
immoral for many
ideological perspective to vote on an
1100 page omnibus with new provisions on
immigration amid a border crisis which
of course is true i've talked at length
before about how i think it violates the
very nature of constitutional government
to provide massive omnibus packages to
the president every bill was supposed to
be designed separately every bill was
supposed to come up for a vote and then
the president had the ability to veto
the reason that the line item veto even
became an issue over the last 30 40
years is because congress routinely
would put together crap sandwiches and
then tell the president to either sign
the crab sandwich or veto the crab
sandwich
it's not how bills used to work so what
exactly is in this thing well according
to Daniel Horowitz over at CR who has a
really good review of it
he says less of a wall than even what
Democrats agreed to Trump originally
demanded 25 billion for the wall then he
negotiated himself down to five point
six billion dollars Democrats box and
only agreed to 1.6 billion dollars this
bill calls it a day at one point three
seven five billion dollars enough to
construct 55 miles but it's worse than
that the bill limits the president's
ability to construct barriers to just
the Rio Grande Valley sector and only
bollard fencing not concrete walls of
any kind there's no ability to adapt in
fact this provision is is so strong that
it's leading people to believe that
Trump may not even be able to use the
national emergency to overcome it
meaning that if the bill itself
restricts the ability to construct
barriers to just a particular area
that's actually a solid legal basis for
saying the president doesn't have
national emergency power to construct
wall wall other places because the way
that we read law in the judiciary is
that last in time is first in priority
so if Congress passes two bills one in
1960 and one yesterday and the one
yesterday overrules the one in 1960 then
the courts will read it that way so if
the national emergencies act of 1976
says the president can declare a
national emergency and build wall which
again is even questionable that's that
but even if it said that if a bill
yesterday came out and said we will not
allow the president to build wall other
than in this small area the bill
yesterday Trump's the the national
emergencies act of 1976 second thing
that's wrong with the budget according
to Daniel Horowitz liberal local
officials will have veto power over the
wall he says it's likely that not a
single mile offense will be built
section 232 a of the bill says in Prior
any funds made available by this act for
the construction of physical barriers
the Department of Homeland Security
shall confer and reach mutual agreement
regarding the design and alignment of
physical barriers within that city they
have to consult the local elected
officials this is why they've limited
the wall to the Rio Grande Valley these
are the most liberal borders on the
these are the most liberal counties on
the Border's order the consequences the
bill stipulates such consultations shall
continue until September 30th 2019 and
may be extended beyond that tape by
agreement of the parties and no funds
made available in this Act should be
used for construction while
consultations are continuing which means
Trump can't build any wall at least
until September and maybe beyond because
he has to consult with all of these
liberal authorities third the bill
contains a blatant amnesty for the worst
cartel smugglers section two two for a
prohibits the deportation of anyone who
is sponsoring an unaccompanied minor
illegal alien or who says they might
sponsor an unaccompanied minor illegal
alien or lives in a household with an
unaccompanied minor illegal alien or
house well that might potentially
sponsor unites an unaccompanied minor
illegal alien so we are now using
children being trafficked across the
border as an excuse not to arrest
illegal immigrants in the country who
may apply as a sponsor or anyone in the
household applying as a sponsor
Jessica Vaughn of the very
anti-immigration Center for Immigration
Studies she says we can call this the
ms-13 household Protection Act of 2019
we know that 80% of UAC sponsors that's
unaccompanied children are in the
country illegally the number of people
this would protect would reach into the
hundreds of thousands if all the
potential or household household or
potential household members are
accounted and forth the the budget bill
contains more funding to manage and
induce the invasion rather than to deter
it there is no new funding for ice
deportation agents it does add another
forty million dollars for the
alternatives to detention program which
moves asylum seekers to facilities in
the interior of the country where they
are usually released that's
catch-and-release and finally it doubles
low-skilled workers it doubles the
number of h-2b non agricultural
unskilled seasonal workers who will
continue to be a public charge on
America according to Daniel Horowitz
that's just a cursory glance through the
bills there's a bunch of problems with
the bill itself now the assumption was
the president Trump would sign this bad
bill and then he would declare a
national emergency according to ABC
today the president is going
to declare some eight billion dollars
for border walls he is he the Daily Mail
actually is reporting that by declaring
a national emergency is going to allow
him to spend eight billion dollars
building his wall after signing that
bill to avoid a government shutdown the
White House confirmed Thursday the
president will sign a bipartisan
spending deal to avoid another
government shutdown but will declare the
national emergency in an effort to
procure funds to build a border wall
Trump will hold an event in the White
House Rose Garden about the border at
10:00 a.m. on Friday
he's expected to sign both the funding
bill and the paperwork for his executive
actions well there's some problems with
the national emergency declaration
number one we have to make sure that he
doesn't limit himself in the budget bill
itself to not being able to do any of
the stuff he's talking about as I
mentioned but number two it is really
unclear whether a national emergency
declaration allows the President of the
United States to mobilize the military
in a non-emergency non-military
situation to build the border wall that
is not clear that that legal precedent
is just not clear Ilia soman over at
reason.com has a good piece on this
explaining the relevant legal issues he
says that some point to 10 USC 2808 and
33 USC 2293 as possible justifications
but section 2808 states that during a
national emergency that requires the use
of the Armed Forces the president can
reallocate defense funds to undertake
military construction projects no threat
posed by undocumented immigration
requires the use of the Armed Forces ice
Border Patrol these are not the Armed
Forces so it's hard to see why a wall
would be necessary to support such use
also it turns out that immigration law
is actually not wartime power
immigration law is domestic law
enforcement section 22 93 only applies
to a war or emergency that requires or
may require use of the Armed Forces
we've never used the Armed Forces with
regard to stopping things at the border
except in rare rare occasions another
federal law allows the military to
condemn property for various purposes
like fortifications but funding has to
be appropriated by Congress to that
purpose as I said yesterday the best
provision of law for the president is
the provision of law us 10 USC 284 that
suggests that the president can declare
certain drug corridors and then build
fencing along those drug corridors but
the idea that he has some widespread
national emergency power and he's not
actually expanding current national
emergency power I think
is foolhardy and opens the door to
precedence I'll explain in just a second
first let's talk about your sleep
quality there's nobody on the planet
like you so why would you buy a generic
mattress built for somebody else Hewitt
sleep has built to sleep quiz it takes
two minutes to complete they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress whether you're a side sleeper
or a hot sleeper whether you like a
plush our firm bed with helix there's no
more guessing in no more confusion just
go to helix sleep calm / men take their
two minute sleep quiz they'll match you
to a mattress that will give you the
best sleep of your life for couples
helix can even split the mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
we've got a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
so what exactly are you waiting for
helix sleep mattresses supremely
comfortable my wife and I have one we
took the two minutes sleep quiz we got
the bed in the mail we pop the mattress
on the frame good to go so comfortable
we got one for my sister for her wedding
right now helix is offering up to $200
off mattress orders for their Presidents
Day sale so thank you George Washington
get up to 200 bucks off at helix sleep
calm / man that's helix sleep calm / man
for $200 off your mattress order for
their Presidents Day sale going on right
now
helix sleep calm / Ben once more helix
sleep calm / Ben go check them out the
mattress is really fantastic so the real
question is if the president declares a
national emergency tries to build the
border wall a couple of questions one is
it legal meaning will it ever be allowed
to be effectuated I think the answer is
probably no I think we'll be held up in
court until at the very earliest late
2020 even if it is not held up in court
even if border wall fencing is allowed
to be built it will be on a small
portion of the border it is quite
possible that the budget deal itself
obviates the legal capacity to build
more wall under a national emergency
declaration as I talked about a little
bit earlier so there's that that's
question number one question number two
even if it gets through is it actually
expanding national emergency powers the
president has used before and the answer
here is yes it turns out that using
eminent domain as an executive power
without congressional authorization
declaring a national emergency on the
basis of failed domestic negotiations
that that is a bad precedent the bad
precedent to set how do we know it's a
bad precedent to set because you can see
the gleam and Nancy Pelosi sigh when she
discusses the kind of national
emergencies she would like to declare if
she had the power to do so here's Nancy
Pelosi's reaction
to the national emergency declaration
it's important to note that when the
president declares its emergency first
of all it's not an emergency what's
happening at the border its manatorian
challenge to us the president that has
tried to sell a bill of goods to no
president is doing and running about
Congress about the power of the purse
you've heard you say over and over again
article 1 the legislative branch the
power of the purse the power to declare
war many other powers are listed in the
Constitution and of course the
responsibility to have oversight so the
president is doing and runned around
that you want to talk about a national
emergency let's talk about today the
one-year anniversary of another
manifestation of the epidemic of gun
violence in America that's a national
emergency ok now you can see her to get
excited when she starts talking about
that is is Nancy Pelosi a wild hypocrite
when it comes to legislative power
versus executive branch power of course
she had no objections to President Obama
wildly at every turn expanding executive
power
none whatsoever she had no problem with
any of that and this is one of the big
problems with honestly the founders did
not believe that party politics would
end up trumping the interests of each
particular branch the founders if you go
back and read the Federalist Papers the
founders believed that the legislature
would be zealous in guarding its own
powers it wouldn't be interested in
allowing the executive branch to
continue expanding its own powers thanks
to the rise of administrative government
backed by Democrats and allowed by
Republicans over the last century since
Woodrow Wilson the executive branch has
spun out of control
most lawmaking does not happen at the
legislative level it happens at the
regulatory level that's all in the
executive branch effectuation of law
happens inside the executive branch
Congress is becoming a vestigial organ
and the only time that Congress is not a
vestigial organ is when there is
actually a gridlock when Democrats
control Congress and Republican controls
the presidency or vice versa when one
party controls both the legislature and
the and the White House then executive
power tends to increase because nobody
in the legislative branch of the party
of the president is going to object to
the president so what you're seeing
right now is Republicans who would
certainly object if Barack Obama tried
to do something like this they would
take legislative action to stop him
right now Republicans are making sounds
like they don't like President Trump
doing what he's doing but are they
actually going to stop him highly highly
doubtful something like ten Republicans
have come out in the Senate and said
they don't like this thing how many
Republicans would be saying they don't
like this thing if Barack Obama were
declaring a national emergency to build
wind farms everybody in the Congress
right there would all say this is absurd
you can't declare national emergency to
do this sort of thing this is a
legislative process the same holds true
for Nancy Pelosi if Barack Obama were
doing that Nancy Pelosi would be talking
about the wonders of the executive
branch and that the founders didn't
understand or they didn't foresee that
party politics would be so strong is to
actually trump the in the interests the
governmental interest of the various
branches it would be more important
whether the president was of your party
than whether the legislature was having
its authority usurped it's a very
dangerous thing it's why the founders
never would have been okay with the rise
of bureaucratic government that's not
their fault they didn't think the
president would ever have this much
power they thought they'd circumscribed
the power of the president not so the
rise of executive branch power has been
everlasting and continuous throughout
the course of the last century and we
are seeing the effects of it now as the
president of both parties does matter
the party continues to usurp more and
more power from the legislature that is
not a good precedent if you think it's a
good precedent wait until there's a
Democratic president guys and don't give
me the well Democrats are gonna break
the rules anyway so Republicans should
break the rules also if you use that
logic honestly if you really believe
that the Democrats are gonna break every
rule to effectuate their policies just a
clerk from dictator and be done with it
it's an argument that proves too much we
do still have certain constitutional and
legal norms in this country that both
parties do hew to for the most part
which is why it's a problem when people
stray from those principles if you
believe that when Democrats take power
they're going to declare the next
president a dictator then you should be
calling for President Trump to simply
override the Constitution and seize
power now so as to prevent a left-wing
dictatorship I don't believe that's the
case I think the constitutional norms
still prevail call me call me foolish
call me optimistic but those
constitutional norms despite gradual
encroachments of power have largely
prevailed over the past couple of
hundred years in the United States okay
meanwhile Democrats proving themselves
incompetent once again as Amazon pulls
out of New York City according to the
New York Times Amazon on Thursday
canceled its plans to build an expensive
corporate campus
York City after facing an unexpectedly
fierce backlash from lawmakers
progressive activists and union leaders
who contended that a tech giant did not
deserve three billion in government
incentives the vast majority of those
incentives by the way or tax breaks now
I've said before I don't believe in
giveaways to specific companies I think
that's crony istic I think that if you
want to have a good working environment
you want to bring business into your
state or city lower the tax rate for
everyone don't give special giveaways to
certain sized companies or to or to
certain big companies that you want to
bring into town with that said was New
York going to lose money by giving tax
breaks no they were not gonna lose money
by giving tax breaks they're gonna gain
money by bringing a giant business into
Queens that was going to bring some
twenty five thousand jobs with it
nonetheless people on the Left do not
understand basic economics and so they
were very pleased with their own genius
here it's pretty hilarious so in a
second I'm going to explain how pleased
everyone was with their own stupidity
it's pretty astonishing we'll explain in
just one second and then we'll get to
our 2020 roundup we have a new thing
that we do on the show that I'm very
excited to bring to you we have theme
songs for every Democratic candidate and
it's pretty great
we'll bring you all that in just a
second first you have to go subscribe
$9.99 a month gets you a subscription to
this show and that brings you all sorts
of goodies we give you guys a lot I mean
three hours of me every single day two
more hours of me later in the day all
you have to do subscribe to get those
on-demand commercial free we bring you
four shows every day if you count
Michael Mills backstage in the
conversation we bring it every month
let's be honest this is more than you
deserve as a human being well starting
next week we want to give you even more
a shout out on this very show to a
different daily wire premium subscriber
every single week and the things we like
if you want to be featured on this show
all you have to do is take a selfie or a
Jif for a video whatever you guys are
into these days you've Millennials you
that includes your leftist here's tumblr
you have to have your leftist ears
tumblr in the picture it could even be
your tumblr and you for example look at
this Here I am holding this tumblr if
you just took a picture of that and I
submitted it I could feature me on the
show why would I want to do that it's my
show instead
I'd rather feature you you have to post
your photo or video or gifs to Twitter
or Instagram with the hashtag hashtag
leftist to tears tumblr that is hashtag
leftist tears to tumblr one word leftist
Tears tumblr that ensures that our team
and the entire world will see you and
your leftist ears tumblr in all of its
glory please include in your post how
long you've been a daily wear premium
subscriber also include your city if
you'd like if you're not a premium
subscriber become one right now and then
you can post a picture of your leftist
tears tumblr on twitter or instagram
with that hashtag leftist ears tumblr
also do not forget if you're not a daily
wire subscriber you are missing out our
next Sunday special guest is Daniel
Krauthammer son of the late Charles
Krauthammer if you're a subscriber you
and only you can watch that episode a
full day early
not only that all upcoming Sunday
special episodes become the Saturday
special but only if you are a daily wire
subscriber now I'm not violating Sabbath
guys we taped it a little bit earlier
what are you waiting for
click to subscribe you will thank me
later 99 bucks a year by the way gets
you the leftist ears tumblr and then you
can join our fun little thing where we
will feature feature you in the things I
like if you pose in a creative way with
the leftist tears tumblr rated PG guys
come on okay get your head out of the
gutter so go check that out right now
also subscribe to YouTube iTunes leave
us a review it always helps we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
already so Amazon was getting mostly tax
breaks to come to New York City there
are certain cash grants that they were
getting because they qualified under
already applicable law in New York for
these cash grants which they shouldn't
have these cash grant programs but
leftists were very angry because they
don't like Amazon the reason they don't
like Amazon is cuz Amazon is big and
Amazon is successful and Amazon provides
jobs now who doesn't actually like
Amazon the answer in New York City is
pretty much no one by polling data the
vast majority of people in New York City
were very much in favor of Amazon moving
into the city that includes some eighty
percent of Hispanics 71 percent of
blacks and 52 percent of white people in
fact it was only white people who are
even mildly divided on the issue it was
not minorities minorities were like hey
man jobs right I mean why not
it was mostly white people who are too
prissy to have a Amazon move in you know
the hipsters like oh no Walmart's coming
to town the mom-and-pop stores gonna go
out of business as opposed to everyone
else is like great Walmart's coming to
town jobs cheap stuff unbelievable so
aoc who believe it or not has an
economics either major or minor still
unclear on this from Boston University
which means that Boston University
should be shut down until we know what
the hell is going on a OC explained her
excitement at thrusting out a company
from her district that would bring some
twenty five thousand jobs to her
district she's a genius I'm telling you
she's a genius so much freshness so much
faceless it's really incredible here she
is spouting utter nonsense that emerges
from that fresh face here we go I mean
it shows that everyday Americans still
have the power to organize
fight for their communities and they can
have more say in this country than the
richest man in the world we could invest
those three billion dollars in our
district ourselves if we wanted to we
could hire out more teachers we can fix
our subways we can put a lot of people
to work for that money if we wanted to
there was no guarantee that those jobs
were for the New Yorkers that were here
I think that we can absolutely come
together to create an economic plan that
actually invests in New Yorkers there
are a few problems of what she is saying
problem number one I love when she says
we could take those three billion
dollars and we could spend them here no
you can't no you can't let me explain
because you're stupid well I'll explain
very slowly using small words and
clipped sentences here's how a tax
incentive works I come to your town and
you say instead of charging me a 30% tax
you will charge me a 20% tax I then
bring my company and I pay a 20% tax on
my income the city is richer for I am
now paying a tax if I were not in the
city the tax would not be paid if you
instead say listen I'm gonna raise that
tax back up to 30% I say okay fine I'm
out you don't then get to claim that
that 10% tax difference is money that is
in your pocket I'm not there to pay the
tax what the hell are you talking about
this is so I mean it's it's not just
economically illiterate it is
mathematically and logically illiterate
it doesn't make any sense at all is the
equivalent of me walking into a pizza
store with a coupon that says five
dollars off and I show it to the guy at
the counter and it was a twenty dollar
pizza and now it's a 15 dollar pizza and
I given the coupon and says you know
what we don't accept that coupon anymore
and say you know what I'm out and I walk
out I go to across the street about
pizza' there and then the guy turns to
his manager and he says I just made us
$20 no you didn't I didn't give you any
money what are you talking about oh my
god even Andrew Cuomo who is just a
dummy even he was like what are you guys
doing are you guys crazy are you crazy I
just say this stuff for a laugh and you
guys say it for real the hell's wrong
with you he issued a statement saying
Amazon chose to come to New York because
we are the capital of the world and the
best place to do business however a
small group of politicians put their own
narrow political interests above their
community why don't you name names go
go for it let's hear it whoo-hoo who are
these people
who would put their own political
interests above the needs of their
community bill de blasio whose economy
he then blamed Amazon for pulling out of
the deal which was hilarious so he
originally was like a big fan of the
deal
and then he's like no no no no the deals
bad you know why cuz Amazon if Amazon
really cared about New York they'd pay
whatever tax we laid on them the New
York Times has a piece today from some
moronic columnist suggesting that New
York just won a victory over Amazon see
when you offer incentives to a giant
company to come to your city and provide
jobs and then you throw them out that's
not actually a victory you're no better
off than when you started
it's but the beautiful thing about being
on the left is that nothing you ever say
has to make any sense it's like truly
this makes no sense like from any
perspective it doesn't make any sense
but that's okay because being on the
left means pandering to the worst
instincts and dumbest people among us
apparently or at least the dumbest ideas
among us okay so which brings us to our
2020 update now we have a new thing
there are too many Democratic candidates
just too many there 1192 one for each
page of the budget bill Democratic
candidates in 2020 so to try and keep
them straight we have added theme music
for all of the various Democratic
candidates and this allows us to bring
you updates so here's our 2020
radicalism update we begin with senator
Elizabeth Warren
[Music]
yeah the colors of the wind man so she
tweeted out about Amazon quote Amazon
one of the one of the wealthiest
companies on the planet just walked away
from billions in taxpayer bribes all
because some elected officials in New
York aren't sucking up to them enough
how long will we allow giant
corporations to hold our democracy
hostage what they walked away from
taxpayer bribes because elected
officials aren't sucking up to them
enough fine keep going with this and
just drive all the business out of the
city I guess that's your I guess that's
your problem it's so funny Elizabeth
Warren used to not be this insane like
really I met Elizabeth Warren and when
she was at Harvard Law School she was at
the welcoming dinner when I was being
recruited for Harvard Law School she was
not a crazy person that like she was a
progressive for sure but she was not a
complete nutjob to suggest that this is
Amazon's fault because New York wouldn't
suck up to them enough wait it's not
sucking up to provide a good business
climate but I guess it is if you're
pandering for that left wing Bernie
Sanders boat which brings us to Bernard
Mick Jaison ders here we go
[Music]
that is the Soviet national anthem for
those keeping track at home so senator
Bernie loves that song by the way sings
it's shirtless in the Soviet Union the
whole deal senator Bernie Sanders
reached out to representative Aloha
Nomar on Tuesday to offer his support
and mid criticism from both Democrats
and Republicans that the progressive
freshman lawmaker trafficked in
anti-semitic tropes on Twitter remember
that time that Steve King lost his
committee assignments from Republicans
and everybody ran screaming away from
him with their hair on fire
Ilhan Omar says anti-semitic things
every five seconds as we discussed on
the podcast yesterday and Bernie Sanders
bear-hug sir because this is what the
progressive left has become they are
fine with anti-semitism they are cool
with anti-semitism in fact they think
that anti-semitism meshes well with the
socialist perspective on the world
because Jews are too successful and
because Jews are too successful this
means that they are part of the
hierarchical free-market structure that
victimizes others Bernie Sanders has
long been anti-israel that's not a shock
a lot of folks on the Left are but
openly embracing anti-semites like Ilhan
Omar pretty amazing apparently Bernie
Sanders said quote I talked to ill hen
last night to give her my personal
support we will stand by our Muslim
brothers and sisters question what makes
you think that all Muslims are
anti-israel anti-semitic bigots isn't
that a little bit judgmental senator
okay so there is your Bernie Sanders
update we have many more of these
candidates many more of them and theme
songs so next bait o O'Rourke so you'll
remember the Congress person from El
Paso hears Beto's theme song man
[Music]
right so you'll recall dit vada Aurora
down on the Texas border punk rocker
bangs in the eyes with your hair man
bata Aurora he's at a rally next to
President Trump the other day and he
talked about the border and while
talking about the border he said that
walls were bad and walls kill people
which led representative Dan Crenshaw to
say well dude do you want to tear down
all those walls and beta owned it like a
bro like dude here he is saying yeah man
I'll tear down that wall because
something and skateboarding if you could
would you take the wall down now here
yes like you have a wall absolutely
knock it down take the wall and do you
think the city you think of this if
there's a referendum here in this city
that would pass I do what it's great I
remember I'm old enough to remember when
the New York Times actually around a
piece saying Republicans pounced they
keep saying Democrats are open borders
fanatics
there's beta1 of your Democratic
frontrunner saying that he would tear
down an actual border wall that exists
and has lowered the levels of illegal
immigration and he says that people in
his city would vote to tear down that
border wall also really keep running on
that let's do that okay on to Senator
Kamala Harris the NARC from California
[Music]
so Pamela Harris has herself an
interesting week she is promoting an
anti-lynching bill which of course is
fine you know I'm very much in favor of
the anti-lynching bill the anti-lynching
bill basically just strengthened federal
crime against lynching which is fine I
mean lynching isn't taking place on a
regular basis but sure good okay
although it seems to me maybe it should
be a state crime instead of a federal
crime but all right so she spoke about
that a little bit yesterday she up but
she also happens to be dominating the
social media primary so according to
media I and a report from Axios when it
comes to the social media attention when
it comes to interactions
it looks like Kamala Harris is winning
so Instagram interactions Harris has
eight point three million Bernie Sanders
comes in at second with 4.6 million
Warren at 2 million twins Twitter
interactions Kamala Harris has 14 point
four million Sanders 8 million war and
4.1 million on Facebook Sanders is
dominating on Facebook he crushes
everyone Sanders says 20 with 2 point 1
million engagements Harris has two point
four million engagements Warren has 2.3
million engagements in the past three
months articles about Harris have
generated about sixteen point five
million interactions on Facebook so it's
pretty obvious than the social media in
the social media arena she is she is
dominant she is growing quickly
the only possible competitor on Facebook
in terms of growth is beta O'Rourke on
Instagram she's added six hundred and
thirteen thousand followers during the
past three months
so lot of momentum for the NARC from
California so well done senator Kamala
Harris okay which brings us to Cory
mcboogerballs
the Spartacus updates the senator from
New Jersey he has a couple of problems
number one he also pushed this
anti-lynching bill but then he said
about the anti-lynching bill that we
need an anti-lynching bill because of
Jesse small its story or no he tweeted
out the vicious attack on actor Jesse
small it was an attempted modern day
lynching I'm glad he's safe so those in
Congress who don't feel the urgency to
pass our anti-lynching bill designating
lynching as a federal hate crime I urge
you to pay attention well we paid
attention and then the story turned out
to be kind of like BSE so there's that
so well done cory booker again
everything he does is two steps too far
the nicolas cage of american politics
in fact people in new jersey don't even
like him I love this poll there's a poll
from New Jersey released early Thursday
it says that Cory Booker would not make
a good president 42 percent of residents
of his own state say that Cory Booker
would not make a good president 37
percent disagree he's good by the way
he's got approval ratings 48 to 36 he
has approval ratings about 48% in New
Jersey but a plurality of state
residents in New Jersey say he would not
make a good president so ouch -
Spartacus apparently Spartacus is going
to be captured by the authorities and
something bad will happen just like in
the movie Spartacus I mean well we have
our Kirsten Gillibrand update as well
the senator from New York known for
taking every position on every issue
nobody knows what kirsten gillibrand
thinks about anything where she is on
any single issue no one knows when you
just take in every position on every
issue which is one of the things that
makes her so wildly unpopular there's a
new poll out from Democratic primary
voters in California then here is how it
comes out it comes out Joe Biden 26%
Kamala Harris 26% kind of shockingly low
for Tamla Harris considering she's a
senator from California Bernie Sanders
at 20 beta at 8 Elizabeth Warren at 7
Cory Booker at 3 and all the way down at
1% below Pete but a gig the mayor of
South Bend Indiana is Kirsten Gillibrand
she is currently tied with Marianne
Williamson the spiritual guru for Oprah
so Kirsten Gillibrand having some
failure to launch so right now if you
have to look at all of those candidates
Kamala Harris is the person who is the
strongest among the candidates bado is
is really steering left in a pretty
radical fashion I promise you when he
was running for Senate in Texas he was
not running on the let's dissolve the
border with Mexico platform turns out
Texans probably wouldn't like that very
much
now he's running on that platform
because he's trying to cut off Kamala
Harris his appeal to Millennials so if
you had to break down the various lanes
in the Democratic Party primary
basically you've got the the
african-american Lane these are the
lanes put out by 538 the
african-american Lane khamel Harris
gonna own that Lane is the presumption
the Millennial Lane bado is going to own
that Lane there's the progressive Lane
that will be split between Sanders and
Warren and bait oh and maybe Kamala a
little bit the mainstream Lane that
would presumably be split if we were
just talking about current candidates
the mainstream Lane would be split
between Kamala Harris and maybe bado so
right now it looks like a two-person
race in terms of Kamala Harris and bado
I think Bernie Sanders is past his prime
I think he's done I think that Elizabeth
Warren is toast as well she's fading
away like a smoke signal off into the
horizon so right now it's beta versus
Kamala unless Joe Biden jumps in which
will get interesting and then we'll have
to come up with some theme song for him
as well so we'll get to the will do that
when when he jumps in I promise you we
need more theme songs because they're 1
million candidates running ok time for a
couple entries in the mailbag so Jared
says hi Ben
I'm a freshman at a small Christian
University in southern Michigan one of
my required courses is devoted to a
study of the Old Testament it got me
wondering who is your favorite biblical
character and why thanks for all of your
hard work um well I mean every Jew is
obligated by law to say Moses because
Moses is of course the the progenitor of
Judaism he was the the man who brought
down the tablets from the mountaintop he
also happens to be an incredibly tragic
character he basically commits one
serious sin and there's argument about
even what that sin is and then God
doesn't allow him to lead the Jewish
people into Israel so it would have to
be Moses I have a sneaking fondness for
Saul I feel is is one of the more
interesting characters in biblical
literature because he obviously suffered
from manic depression and you can see
that in the literature and he was
somebody who's trying to do his best but
was limited by his own flaws so he's
almost a Shakespearean tragic character
when the character of Phineas is is an
interesting character as well
phineas of course was famous for his
Ella tree you'll recall that in the book
of notes Bamidbar
in the book of numbers phineas there's a
there's a situation where somebody is
committing an open sin and Phineas takes
up a spear and goes and kills that
person out of zealousness and there's a
whole argument Jewish law about when you
can do this in one you can't really
interesting argument there those are a
couple my favorites Joshua says hi Ben
I'm currently applying to medical school
and I'm shocked by how new science has
pervaded the entire process when
studying for the MCAT I learned that the
official AMC the company that makes the
test prep materials and practice exams
essentially guaranteed a question
stating the gender has no biological
basis the vast majority of secondary
applications to school had a checkbox or
if I identified as part of the LGBTQ
community they were there were leading
interview questions to discuss how
gender norms are different in other
countries they have any advice on how to
approach this issue in medical school
is it better to deduct my head down
until I practice or to be more outspoken
throughout shabbat shalom
well you know I think keeping your head
down is probably the smart move I'm I'm
practical when it comes to this the
question is what is the purpose of the
conversation if the purpose of the
conversation is to tell the truth
and to speak your opinion say what you
want but I assume that there are lots of
areas of American practice in in
medicine where you might have political
disagreements for example if you're
asked a question about how abortion is
done and you say listen I don't think I
need to know that because I'm a
religious person I'm not going to
perform
abortion is that is that answer
calibrated to get you to your goal the
answer is probably not you do have to
play some games when it comes to
American professional life and that's
unfortunate it is also a demonstration
that we should have accredited medical
schools that don't participate in this
kind of garbage the fact that the
scientific establishment has been taken
over by politically correct anti
scientific nonsense it's really
devastating it's devastating to watch's
objective science is tossed out in favor
of subjective silliness that is pumped
into medical institutions by politically
motivated actors Nathan says there are
several studies in the academic
literature detailing the correlation
between perceived discrimination and the
health of an individual in addition
there's no doubt in my mind that actual
discrimination is negatively correlated
to health this led me to wonder about
the effects that identity politics and
intersectionality have had on the health
of Americans especially in the minority
community but I couldn't find a study
that looked at all three actual
discrimination perceived discrimination
in health at the same time that said can
you point to anything that has
correlated perceived discrimination with
negative health while also determining
the accuracy of the group's perceptions
this is a fantastic question and it's a
question I have asked repeatedly so
there are a lot of studies in the recent
past about how black women died in
childbirth more often have more
unhealthy babies and the suggestion has
been made that this is the result of
systemic discrimination I have real
doubts that the medical establishment is
severely under covering black women who
are in labor or pregnant when when there
are higher maternal mortality rates
higher baby mortality rates in the black
community those things are largely
linked to birth weight and birth weight
is largely linked to living style what
you eat and such and also youth if
you're a younger if you're a teenager
when you have a baby you tend to have
low birth weight problems but the
studies also tend to show that women who
perceive discrimination are more likely
to suffer stress and therefore to suffer
pregnancy related complications
the question that no one has ever been
able to verify or ask is how much of the
perceived discrimination is real now
here I bring up a very famous statement
by Adam Carolla that I think is true I'm
not saying that people are hallucinating
racism I'm saying that there's lots of
action in life everyday that can either
be perceived as people being stupid or
perceived as actual discrimination so
when I was growing up for example my dad
had a tendency when I was much younger I
think he's grown out of it now but when
I was much younger my dad had a tendency
where if he see if he saw somebody
mistreat a Jew for some reason he would
immediately assume that it was
anti-semitism and I would say well maybe
it's not anti-semitism maybe it's the
person just being a jerk Adam Carolla
has said the same he says listen if I
were a black person driving down the
highway and are pulled over by the cops
I would immediately assume it was racial
profiling maybe it's just being maybe
it's just the cop being a tool maybe
it's just a cop being a jerk or a bad
guy because it turns out that lots of
white people get pulled over for no
reason
by the cops or maybe it turns out that I
am not correctly perceiving my own
activity and I actually did violate the
law there's really no way except for
cases like murder right where there's a
documented effect to look at racial
discrimination in for example the
criminal justice system the only way to
match up police discrimination would be
to match up for example the number of
calls to the police describing purpose
of a particular race to the number of
arrests that are made by the police of a
particular race it turns out those
percentages match up exactly in other
words perception of human beings is
notoriously unreliable and studies that
take as their basis that perceived
discrimination equals actual
discrimination are likely to be off by
maybe an order of magnitude I mean to
real social science problem Gregory says
hey Ben while talking with my lady over
some cherries berries yesterday I had to
eat some too
indeed cherries berries phenomenal
phenomenal oh man they have kosher
chocolate chocolaty goodness
unbeliev mind-blowing as we discussed
the idea of possibly taking a vacation
we both put out some ideas but couldn't
really decide what is the best place for
your money where do you believe
stateside or overseas is the first place
a young couple should spend some time to
experience something different and maybe
learn something new Thanks well I have
to admit that I have not spent a ton of
time abroad I'm a big fan of the United
States the place that I thought was
coolest that I had visited outside of
Israel which I have some religious
reasons for thinking is pretty awesome
if you're a religious person Israel's
unbelievable if you're a person who
likes history and and is a Christian or
a Jew or Muslim frankly Israel is an
amazing place to visit an incredible
place to visit if you are if you are a
Catholic if you love history if you love
culture if you love art I love Italy
Italy is spectacular I've been to Italy
with my wife went there for a week and I
was just blown away by it it's fantastic
amazing Rome is incredible it's Italy is
an astonishingly great place so that
that's that's really
if you if you're just looking for a
place to chill out Hawaii is still the
best place on earth I'm very glad the
United States annexed it simply so I
could make Haitian their personal
selfishness coming into play right there
but Hawaii is fantastic and you don't
actually have if you don't want to learn
anything you just want a vacation then
you go check out Hawaii Brody says I
hear a lot of people on the Left saying
that global warming is the biggest
threat America I find this to be untrue
but in your opinion what would you say
are some of the biggest threats in
America the biggest threat in America is
people not understanding the American
bargain and believing that America is
all about guaranteeing you free stuff
rather than freedom that is the biggest
threat to America as Americans who don't
understand our own history who don't
care about our own history or
intolerance of other people's opinions
who believe that they should be able to
use the government as a club to compel
people to do what they want that is the
biggest danger to America the biggest
dangers to America are from within they
don't have to do with a giant tsunami
that's gonna hit the coast they don't
even have to do a terrorism they have to
do with the American Republic losing
sight of its own way I wrote an entire
book about this the right side of
history you should go check it out it's
coming out soon it's I put my heart and
soul into it I think you'll enjoy it
Marcus has been I recently had a
discussion with my cousin who just got
back from South Korea about universal
health care and Insteon Falls she
mentioned that surprisingly it has been
very successful out there she said it
was much more effective and expedient
than when she went to doctors here in
the states have you read or seen
anything regarding their system or have
any input on the validity of its
effectiveness I don't know enough about
the South Korean system I have been
looking at the United States healthcare
system in some detail over the past
couple of weeks because I really want to
know more about how it compares and
contrasts with other health care systems
around the world the truth is the United
States does have a heavily subsidized
public sector healthcare system 49% of
all healthcare spending in the United
States is done by the government about
66 percent of people in the United
States are covered by employer provided
health care insurance market incentives
are largely skewed by Medicaid and
Medicare but one area in which the
United States is head and shoulders
above everyone else there they're a
couple of places and where in which the
United States is head and shoulders
above every other health care system on
planet earth number one you got cancer
we win if you have cancer you have a
grave disease you don't want to be
anywhere else you want to be even the
place where you can get convenient care
and pay for it you don't want to be in a
system where you have to wait on line
and they have rationed care for
specialists and there aren't enough
specialists because they're not being
paid enough in the United States is
still number one in it by it by up with
a bullet right by it by a long way in
terms of survival five
years after diagnosis of cancer I think
in second place is Switzerland which
also has a very privately based
healthcare insurance system it just has
an individual mandate that is not
connected to your employer the United
States is all really where the United
States is head and shoulders above
everyone else is also when it comes to
the production of new goods and services
the United States is responsible for
over half of the world's medical patents
we are responsible for the vast
majorities of new drugs that come onto
the market and we pay a premium for that
the reason all these companies located
in the United States is because we don't
use the government to cram down prices
on these RMD companies so for all the
talk about the United States and how
much we spend on healthcare we also make
an enormous amounts of money on
healthcare the healthcare industry is an
enormous growing industry in the United
States the entire city of Pittsburgh is
basically employed by the healthcare
industry where it used to be coal mining
country so there are some real upsides
to the US healthcare system the
downsides are that that when it comes to
emergency care it's more expensive the
downsides are that there's no
quote-unquote universal healthcare
coverage although Medicaid basically
provide something close to it but when I
take any other system over the United
States is not really I mean the only
other one I think that is even remotely
comparable really is is maybe the Swiss
healthcare system and that's because I'm
not looking for what everybody else is
looking for in a healthcare system I
care far less about equality of outcome
in a healthcare system I care much more
about the ability to access new products
and services the ability to get care on
demand the United States does not have
month-long wait times for doctors I
haven't looked at South Korea I'm just
contrasting the United States with for
example France which is the system
everybody seems to like a lot on the
left and again I think the reason that I
favor this is because I'm a free-market
person on a moral level I don't believe
that it's my job to pay for your health
care I think that I can if I'm
charitable but if we have an incentive
system that is so skewed that the
government pays for everybody's health
care you're gonna get a lot more
dependence you're gonna get a lot more
demands on the healthcare system and a
lot less supply unless you radically
raise taxes which is basically what's
happened in Europe alrighty let's see
one more question Jeremy says hi Ben you
have mentioned that you work out what
does your routine do you lift or do you
just do cardio do you even lift bro so I
do not do a lot of lifting I know it's
trendy I do a fair bit of CrossFit
meaning I do a lot of pull-ups I do a
lot of push-ups I do a lot of throwing
of medicine balls I do a lot of
kettlebell swings and and push presses
and that sort of stuff so that means
that you know I'm in pretty good shape I
mean I can knock out probably 30
pull-ups straight
I cannot get 100 pushups straight pretty
easily but you know I'm not I'm not
built like a Mack truck that's it and
listen I mean I'm I don't want to get
arrogant here but beneath this this
humble exterior lies the body of a Greek
god but it happens to be a slightly
skinnier Greek god I'm not gonna be in
any bodybuilding competitions all righty
time for you know what to even have time
for things I like and things I hate
today I think we may have run out of
time
for things I like and things I hate so
you know what let's just skip it we'll
do it next week but today later on the
show we have two more hours it's gonna
be great there's so much good stuff
coming up on the show later today not
only do we have a couple of great guests
but also I'm going to be doing Uncle
Ben's SJW children's book reading and
it's fantastic we did it last week this
week we feature a book by Richard Scarry
that is so politically incorrect it will
make minds melt for all the parents on
the left which is why they should read
it because it'll be good for them we'll
see you then i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19